things are about to get weird uh
miyazaki
you should look away in this video
you'll learn
where to find the ak-47 in dark souls 3
why they decided not to make sakura
multiplayer
how to attack with your own pet rock
lizard hell you can even be
your own rock lizard what a time to be
alive and
it's all thanks to these mods and their
creators linked in the description
first though the jojo mod by zuli the
witch
which is a small part of her challenge
mod collection
so jojo's bizarre adventure is a great
anime that
you should try and watch where
characters stand in fabulous poses
and attack with creatures that are
manifestations of their own energy
called stans in this mod you do a
similar thing
the mod pulls enemies from the world
around you
and then turns them into equippable
attacks that do different moves
based on your r1 r2 and l2 presses
oh that's useful wait does he transform
oh he can't he transforms and some of
these stands are actually so perfect
for the fights they're available for
some have buffs that they keep some are
powerful at range and a lot of them
are broken admittedly but the trickiest
thing to manage is that a lot of them
will get caught behind you
which leaves you pretty vulnerable when
you need to attack which means you end
up using invincibility frames quite a
lot because you can't beat them up
without getting closer
now the stands you have available change
as you go through the world you'll
gain new ones and lose old ones so the
persistent goal while you're playing
this mod is always to just
cycle through and find the most
overpowered one for the level that
you're in and once you do
it's a lot of fun and all in all
constantly unlocking new attacks as you
progress through the game is
just a great time because you're
constantly adapting your playstyle and
since you don't use weapons you don't
need to worry about upgrading your
weapons with titanite and i mean it's
not like you were going to get much
titanite anyway let's be honest but you
know what's better
than summoning powerful stands to defeat
your enemies
summoning a fully loaded ak-47 firing
600 rounds per minute with infinite ammo
the gun mod is by forsaken silver and
you can use it in conjunction with the
zuli's challenge mod
which adds third person mode and a high
fov
first person mode for maximum immersion
and another cool thing about this mod is
that it can also be used in conjunction
with the cinders mod which is one that
we mentioned last time
and if you remember the cinders mod
drastically changes the entire
dark souls 3 experience adding tons of
new weapons
like the drake sword from the original
dark souls
there are new spells summer of powered
and some
[ __ ] and some are overpowered and [ __ ]
the enemy placement is pretty genius
sometimes
take this section for example you get
attacked by a ton of thieves at once if
you're not careful
who overwhelm you with throwing knives
but then
they also drop a ton of throwing knives
so you're supposed to use their own
knives against them
lure them out one by one and take them
out slowly
and that's sort of a thing about this
mod it is slow going
you can't run through everything as
easily as you would when you're playing
retail
and it's tough especially since all the
bonfires have moved as well
but i mean that's why you played dark
souls in the first place isn't it
if you're really into the rpg aspects of
dark souls then
you'll love this because there's a ton
of things like weapon infusion passives
you can mark your world with things like
extra dogs
extra crabs or more enemies or you know
all of the above these curses often come
with other blessings though and
it's interesting to be able to tweak
your world to suit your playstyle
but the point i'm trying to make though
is cinders is hard
harder than when i played it last time
that's for sure for that reason
i felt no guilt when i pulled out my
trusty ak-47
every time i ran out of estus because
you got to do what you got to do
and even if that random spray creates
problems for you sometimes
it also solves those problems in much
the same way
but hey you know what's better than
using guns to defeat your enemies
using the power of friendship i don't
remember how do this play it's been a
while
i think you just spammed yeah i think
you just spammed one and then you just
can't attack
securo online is an ambitious enterprise
by luke huey
granting you a cursed emblem to summon
friends ariel did you get the double
yeah we did we got the double we got the
double and avengeful spirit
to invade them impressively it actually
does a lot of things
better in regards to online to a lot of
the previous souls games
since for example you can easily invite
your friends to your world via steam
without needing to set passwords or put
your summoning sign down in a random
corner of the world
and your world progress like defeating
bosses
is actually shared between you and your
summons so
you can almost do a play through
together instead of being
out of sync with the other person all
the time it made me realize that there's
really no excuse for souls being so
behind in a lot of ways although as
impressive as this mod is it does
kind of help you understand why sakura
was never designed for co-op or pvp it's
kind of busted
and i don't think they ever could have
made it work without sacrificing the
quality of the single player experience
get up don't let get up just spam him
you can't stay there forever and there's
no stamina in this game he's [ __ ]
so thank you guys for watching this
whoa now that i've stopped time for a
few seconds i have a minute
to discuss our sponsor nordvpn stopping
time
is a reference from jojo's bizarre
adventure but
you would only know that if you're able
to watch the show it's available on
netflix in
some countries but only japanese netflix
seems to have every season right now so
you're gonna want to pretend you're in
japan to get around the region lock
that's where nordvpn comes in it's just
one click and
you can pretend you're anywhere right
now you can get 68 percent off a
two-year plan
plus one additional month for free when
you go to nordvpn.com
or use code varity video link in the
description that makes your subscription
just
371 per month and it's worth it simply
by virtue of the fact that
you can double or triple the amount of
content that you get from
streaming subscription services that you
pay for nordvpn
can also be used to enhance your
security for example
while playing games like sakura online
your ip is potentially exposed
to the person that you're matched with
in a peer-to-peer connection
so nord can help you to hide that
connection at the other side of the
world
to keep yourself safer in a lot of
situations you can currently access over
5 000 servers in
59 countries and that number is always
increasing
so you're sorted wherever you want to go
so click the link in the description and
go to nordvpn slash varity video
or use code varividia to help me out and
tell me in the comments what you use a
vpn for maybe we can all figure out some
of the shows that are only available to
you in your countries
and nowhere else let me know thank you
for listening and
i'll see you next time